all right so let's just take a moment
and close our eyes and use this minute
to we check in with yourself so here's
the chance we've been relating for the
last hour or two and here's a chance to
deliberately take all your attention off
of everybody else and give it back to
yourself for a moment a few slow breaths
noticing what it's like to be you in
this fresh moment what are you feeling
physically
what are you feeling emotionally
just to recognize okay this is this is
where I am now this is how I'm showing
up so so as it changes during the circle
then I could probably attribute that to
the interaction but this is where I'm
this is home base this is what I'm
starting with
and then slowly open your eyes take a
few seconds to look around and connect
again with with a few people that are
here just let your eyes land and to stay
there for a couple of seconds before you
move on
and then let's go ahead and bring our
attention with Sophia
I feel like a peacefulness enough
a softness being with you right off the
bat
I feel a sense of the away like you feel
really available into my heart I don't
know how else to put that
and I imagine a there's something about
what occurs to me is a like a pre
reflective responsiveness to what's
around you that like had me feel really
just generous by being
and I thank you
- here how did that impact you
hearing you Phil I am very available to
the world
it's
hard work
I want to be available to
[Music]
you just got he's got reflect my like I
just reflected to you that your way if
you want to be yes precisely
yeah I have a sense that I'm noticing
like I'm watching your mouth kind of
smile and your eyes water both at the
same time what's going on there
I have a lot of antecedent to the world
to extend that I don't think my own
capability where I was born my
experience that my quote/unquote social
status that cannot really support such a
man of empathy that I have towards the
world so was people around me
the moment I got recognized that I'm so
open
to the world I also want to connect to
that it's when I felt recognized
and the heart
so you have so much empathy for the
world that isn't usually able to be
received by people and when it can be
received like it is now like you just
come alive yeah like maybe let's put it
up like maybe I fo the world is don't
not do not want to see it especially in
this town
probably
I'm not artificial intelligent because I
have too much emotions right yeah the
other day I look at the map right here
I tell Alan I said Wow
it is just a digital map
but as people under the roof that we
cannot see the people had the experience
same pain same happiness they have their
own things to worry about there are
struggles and things they're proud of
the picture it's very much alive to me
it's so vibrant
I just stared a map I want to cry
it's weird you know like I've noticed
that too like tears tears seem to like
you a lot
mm-hmm Isis water sign so what happened
yeah
you said you mentioned something I heard
you say fish is something I think if I
caught this correctly yeah you felt like
where you were from which is where would
you um really small town from China yes
totally like so there was a sense I
think whatever to say is like where you
were from they didn't have it they
didn't have a map for you know what are
you supposed to be like I'm just curious
I'm supposed to be having kids
happily marries their home not that is
wrong at all just different life path
right
be very happy with taking care of my
himself my family call it a day enjoying
the little micro movement of being a
human being which you can learn a lot
too
every little cell is life
and that
deserve to be respected versus me I
bounced around a lot and I want to
experience more when I was little we yes
there's no map about my hometown but
there's a map available of the world I
just look at the map I love it I just
like I want to go there there and this
someday so and that's what I did later
on where did I get so much empathy I
think it's because I desire to
experience the world so I want to feel
connected how do you feel connected is
by putting yourself into other people's
shoes that's where empathy breeders from
yeah
I've never tried to make sense of it
till now
I like I'm just noticing I'm looking
forward to you making sense of what you
haven't tried to make sense of before
yeah there's a lot of surprises tonight
yeah what's it like for you
he just think about me just look around
what's it like just being being here
with us and you had mentioned before we
started that like having a lot of it
like attention I knew was his there's
intense
what is it turning out to be for you
though I felt a genuine care and
curiosity and I that ease my nerves
of luring that I'm wasting other
people's time and attention secondly
what I feel is if I shared in a most
authentic way I think
I can enjoy the attention a little bit
more yeah
I noticed seagull mm-hmm ah what's it
like being there
so far with coming from the small town
looking in the math and see
about the things I want experience at
least I want to go and going against the
grain
no I think I want to get married first
that comes with that I told me what it's
made of that yeah
beautiful to be with you because it
seems
so the words of my heart and it feels
very comfortable to know that someone is
so open
and I've never been to China Lord go
after his friends sir just in a very
very deeply human
what was that experience like could you
share hearing that how does that impact
you
I am a colorblind person
anybody for me it's you
but sometimes they tend to forget
that experience she's sharing what's me
reinsured we confirmed
colorblind is the right way
yeah
I've seen a documentary before it's
called what day
24 hours collectively
user-generated content and say hey you
filming that what's going on and around
all the corner of the world at 7:00 in
the morning 5:00 and afternoon and then
review it
Collective documentary and you can tell
everybody doesn't matter what levels of
income you have what color is studying
skin or
you go through the same things different
levels yeah
say if I'm married at home I'd probably
go through the same thing I feel a
little trapped but I have a lot of
responsibilities should I go try this at
that vs. me I'm here I started my
company no kiss no husband inside
I feel a little trapped should I start a
new company find new partners manure the
trapped degree is probably the same it's
just different life paths people like me
like you
yeah that's what I felt when she
responded back to me the third thing is
she felt like home
it's funny because I've always tried to
ever since I left in my own little home
I always try to find a home for my
and never be able to
I've seen the quotes like Oh home is
where heart is where you feel most
content right never quite on this other
student I have fraction of moments I
understand it when I surrounded myself
with friends that understood me and care
about me when that made my happy place
at work but when something dis balanced
a little bit I feel just not home
anymore I don't like this should I leave
should I run away
it's interesting to hear what she just
said I feel like home it's I think home
probably is a decentralized a place
where it only appears in moments for
moments if your husband phyto his wife
at home that the husband wouldn't feel
like home anymore
he just want to slam the door on me hmm
but if they're in a good relationship
that's home right that applies a lot of
things just like now is this home I
don't like it second time I stepped into
space
in a sense that I this place makes me
feel like home and a long time
I just mad at all of you at the first
time we are feeling to me yeah so so on
some level and some levels something
that you've been like looking for
listening for tuning into he's actually
here right now yeah like home yeah so so
we just kind of like allow that sense of
home just to be here after 70 days just
let it unfold and then describe to us
like
what is it like
I step in I had my barbecue was dinner
in my hands it's like oh maybe we have
break I don't know what circling is I'm
gonna enjoy my barbecue or oh I have a
lot of emails having to reply and my
lawyer is my accountant my business
partners my later appointment was past
two hours I haven't even want to check
out myself
and such as seeing seeing like without
even thinking about it I haven't noticed
that I wasn't looking for something else
to do right like my experience here is
not had we want to be anywhere else
yeah what's it like just could notice
that yeah
of really being human
it's such a precious and more and more
difficult things to do it's
curved structure of society
and moment like this you cherish it
and how do I create warm
walk out from this circle
hardest question
like
for just one second solo
thing that I've just that the common the
common thing that I've heard you talk
about so far
is
humanity
and in home
in your connection with humanity
and I I get this sense of just like on
one level it's interesting because I
feel pretty at home with you and what I
think that I'm hearing is it at a level
maybe even more than you actually may be
where you're finding out just like right
now like you've been looking for
hit
here's some of the things I'm sort of
piecing together so tell me how this
fits and what else is there
so you're this incredibly empathetic
being and
other people haven't
you haven't had a lot in your life of
where people like we're able to fully
receive it fully take that in the gift
of that and and and the appreciation and
the love of that and yet you you
continue to be empathic with people but
I think even on a broader scale what I
notice with you is in addition to that
more so with than most people I I meet
like your empathic to the world but
you'll look at a map and go into tears
because you'll be tuning into like the
pain of the world and taking that end
and like that hasn't been received and
and so part of that looking for home is
like like how do like how do how am I
receive like how am i honored and loved
for like the gifts I bring and so now
you're sitting here with people like
you're getting your your empathy I those
tears coming out and and I think one of
the things I'm getting is is not only
has that not been received but maybe you
haven't been around people who actually
empathize with you personally
where the whole cycle is it's complete
just let those tears happen
what could like to hear that out loud
I have comments like this from my
previous partners that
easy to love you had to live with
I have this desire
to find love find the right partner
recognized my value in life but once
they found me and I found them I tend to
run away I think is that half of its
because you said you tension right away
yeah
I don't think that's common but it's
because I lost my dad
I just that hailing is everyday work the
whole is always has always been there
I just turned to shut it down
I'm certain with her this today marks 10
years
hmm
I think that lost the courage of what
as a daughter grow up I lost the courage
that a father could provide to the
daughter
it is invisible power that
I can never put such thing in worse
but I know it's missing
say you're it constantly wants to find a
reliable with loyal lovely partner those
we see seen really
when I found it
I felt something that they reliably
reliable biological bonded party like my
dad could just leave me right away how
come I can trust that person that I
found in life he can just run away
so the moment they got close to people
is the Roland I want to be more
independent be less attached and run
away
it's like a curse I see myself as a lab
rats Ronnie on a treadmill but I don't
know how to get out because you might
have to experience that kind of hurt
again yeah and cruelly incredibly open
but also incredibly protective about
myself that when I was reading the book
about Einstein said he is a horrible
human being where people around him
close to these families but he has a lot
of empathy to the world for strangers to
humanity's
he care about bringing wisdom and the
truth to the world so has sacrified his
personal emotions and care to people
around him
because this Einstein was like oh that's
cool
I sound familiar like look at the map I
care about what people how are they
doing
underneath the digital roof yet I cannot
provide that to people around me what
like why I couldn't like get it
but I felt really sad hearing that and I
also feel like that like Justin like the
intensity of having something so old and
primal and like before before I could
even before I could even think about it
that stays with me and now trying to
figure it out and it just seems like
it's such a hard catch-22 it's like this
this love that I've yearned for that
never really I was able to have because
my father left and then when I get
something that resembles that I run from
it
so I make sure I can't have it because I
don't want to have the pain of losing it
again giving it back to you you just
take a moment what's it like here in a
truth--it of yourself spoken from him
first I really appreciate that you
really hear hear me
it's the part what's the part really
here hear me what's the part that no he
thought really heard that he felt bad
for me I feel that's really authentic
and genuine I would feel bad for someone
who's suffering from this endless loop
illusion what is this suffering like so
I heard you say it's basically like he
and really he he heard her be yeah
really heard there really had to do with
he connected to the suffering what is it
we just take a moment and just feel into
like
how does that how do you suffer
I can tell you as you are talking the
word like a word that just came came out
for me it was like lost yeah look I can
actually kind of get from what you're
talking about how would be really
confusing like being you searching for
what on some level I knew all right away
from if I find it but just the sense of
just the sense of like being a lost
is that president
constantly have two voices in my head
one is okay you know yourself looking at
the past connecting dots find a better
solution
it's just stand up and you know break
the old thinking patents and behavior
patterns on the other side it's constant
tangle dancing with old version of you
because it's comfortable because you
know you already taken their path I
don't know if anyone or everyone is also
having the struggle constantly
internally with just different versions
of yourself quite a little bit different
from what I'm having possibly if that's
the truth then I feel less lonely yeah
look and then you said like
essentially here you are you just
presented death what's it like just
being you sharing sharing the place that
you suffer or some of the makes you
suffer you just look around is this like
an unusual experiences no you're like
it's not unusual experience but the
amount of attention than a response and
emotion I feel emotionally responsible
for all of you sitting here listening
yes yeah yeah I felt I should get as
deep as authentic
and put a put put my words as logical as
I could to be understood therefore that
I can make I don't know make you feel a
little more connected yeah
and I feel like that
question five
and in a way getting to know really
someone is no
what is it for them
and how did he perceive themselves on
that request
success
or
a different time
yes
I mean of course
right finding home but something that in
the past
finally realizing that
this body
just hearing you talking about
mr.
yeah
what's me want to cry again it's funny
if I met you in the random coffee shop I
won't just oh a girl with short hair
pretty
vibrant positive that's the most icons
and then I mean little did I know right
many years ago I want to let date
I had a weird feeling it's like before
he walked in I already have a pre
projected image in my head what he
should look like and then when his sit
down
he was so present unlike any other day
that I've been I feel wow whenever I sit
in a one spot
having
were exchanging with you it's not only
me talking to you at this moment
particular time it's me with years of
experiences pains happiness people
talking to me all the wisdoms I get from
my teachers mentors everything combined
my expectations I sit here it's a
combination of energy I don't know if
his energy just combination of things
they're talking to another combination
of things there it's so complicated and
there's so many ways that can connect
yeah I'm just having that thought I had
a really good conversation with that
date so yeah I just didn't really enjoy
the moment like like just the way that
you like your response when I would look
at your face just just I just love I'm
just really enjoying watching you be
recognized I think thank you look like
in being a sense of just like enjoying
your surprise and
imagining imagining that we're kind of
all together finding out what what is
home like what the home is for you like
we're all I feel like I'm discovering
that with you somehow in these moments
of recognition I always ask they also
really like also just appreciate it like
that the thing that you brought up too
is like well if we're talking about home
the thing that gets in the way of like
finding home right is oh there's like a
place where actually what I think I
maybe find it I can I can count on
myself to like run away from it yeah and
it sounds like that was connected to
something going on with your dad and I
just kind of feel that sense of just
like I felt more I felt my own
humaneness and all of my my particular
fear is about connection and not
interested
I've sometimes questioned myself like
listen Sophie you're so emphatic so
connected with the world and also love
to think I picked my own name
Sophie because it's philosophy and a
love that's translated how much I love
about thinking I'm like okay take a deep
breath and think when are you ready to
be settled in a home and I have really
good eyes to recognize goodness in
people to kindness so it's in a sense
that it's easy for me to find love but
I'm wasn't ready for love right so I ask
myself when it's the top right time and
then I fell when is the time to to
exercise your full potentials it's the
right time to call yourself as a
complete human being is the right time
you do not no longer need to project
your own desire to other human beings
that you called lover you're complete
you don't rely on other people as a
complete human being go to love another
human being that's the most authentic
way maybe I'm being too ideal I feel
like I haven't lived my full potential
yet so I found someone who's lovable and
loves me back
the moment he loves me vodka I ran away
I think one is because I lost the
courage of the my father passed away
secondly it's because I feel like I
always haven't haven't left to my full
potential yet yeah I don't know if
that's a common sense
we have internally well what happens the
moment before that the moment before
what before you run silent and I create
spiritual distance violent violent yeah
what happens before that the other
person who want to live with me forever
say you hear that
like what comes up in you
what if I die tomorrow am i just leaving
with this person forever what a waste of
life of limited lifetime selfishly so is
that you is it you're tapping into like
a place of like getting closed in or
trapped or possibilities limited or
something else I will feel trapped
trapped yeah that fell I couldn't leave
fully to this such precious short
lifetime trapped that same thing as my
dad's being trapped
he's never being able to see what I'm
doing what his daughter is being able to
accomplish whose daughter is marrying to
like all the wonderful things in life
yes please go ahead I just want to ask
one more thing yeah and then right after
you leave do you feel more free or do
you feel like you've lost something or
or something else I both in different
time right after I feel vulnerable but
it's the time where I gather most of my
self-confidence to be independent again
leave in another potential version of
myself when I constantly take another
path and moved on I look back the
memories filtered all the bad ones the
good ones collectively formed like
little crystal whenever I look back I
see through good memories like all two
people fall in love I did really
wonderful time help each other grow
reforming each other it's always there I
remember all the loved friends and loved
and families in my life good moments
yeah but only good things yeah
not in a deep way yeah
yes yeah like I'm weighs myself
exactly there's no yes there's no
obligations no responsibilities I'm
refocusing on myself again no need to
compromise when to go home to have
dinner who's washing the dishes and if I
don't too much Network event is he feel
like been ignored by me a lot of things
yes yes definitely yes very very
important and you describe like a sense
of of wanting to feel complete in and of
yourself like when you meet your partner
yes I'm wondering are you not feeling
that sense from the partner so you've
ended up with like that they have that
where they're feeling complete in and of
themselves but instead like you're
feeling their love but also their
neediness mmm-hmm for sure and that's
almost intolerable yes yeah I can only
taller it low enough yeah yeah I there's
maybe there's many different ways to
form a happier couple or happy partner
friendship yeah Parenthood one is rely
on each other therefore it's locked
there's no way to go you you go wherever
other people go another ways complete
you don't need me I don't need you
there's something in you something in me
that just keep us attracted to each
other we go if you want a distance a
little bit that's okay I know we're
gonna come back yeah that's what I want
but I have yet to found it I think the
first step to be able to find it is one
be complete circle yourself right yeah
that's what I am I'm still going that
this way I just don't
when that can be a complete self yeah
but that thing is on your way of
becoming a complete version of yourself
there's a lot of other circle a half
circle will find you they thought your
zit you're the one but you know you're
not they're just passing through yeah I
mean it's starting to sound to me like
you're having great relationships you're
having lots of love and then you sort of
get to a point you go okay like that was
great and they're not my perfect match
right and so now I'm moving on and I'm
growing and I'm learning
I don't now I'm wondering it like it
almost doesn't sound like it's this
thing that you're attributing to your
dad you know to me it just sounds like
you having being in touch with yourself
having a level of emotional intelligence
and maturity of like what's right for
you and like you haven't met like one
you haven't maybe quante got to the
place where you want to be before you
kind of settle down and have your match
and to like you haven't actually found
your match it's sort of like a calm in a
way kind of both you haven't become your
match and you haven't found your match
yes but how do I get to the point is
just by having my own philosophy about
it is why do I choose the path of the
complete circle first why didn't I just
choose the path of being able to
completely trust another party and lock
to each other down and help each other
to grow it's because I feel this way is
actually more vulnerable because what
about the party just passed away he just
left he's gone
I think by being a complete circle is
selfishly the ultimate way of
self-protection yeah so you feel like
you're avoiding some level of
vulnerability yes by not being willing
to commit to somebody even if you don't
know yet if they're right or not yeah
yeah that makes sense yeah yeah how do
you form your value of life to choose
what type of relationships soup for you
I think yes if there's different stage
of life but once you pass 30 you sort of
figured out how do you what's the way of
figuring it out it's a lot of life
experiences of dear family members
passed away it's passed broken
relationships teach you little things
here and there is by being here circling
hearing feedbacks I feel my dad's
absence is the critical elements for me
to form this I need to be complete
circle first yeah
I really appreciate that question I
think it's a right yeah yeah what's
important most important than love is it
goes back to my parents gave me a
Chinese name sure
it means the Rising Sun in the morning
brings happiness positive energy to
people to this state I try to live up to
the name I think what the name
represents the meaning is my life
mission I think that's more important
than love that contains love love
belongs to this yeah yeah yeah
yeah life mission yeah yeah have us
yeah love is its daily mmm social
responsibility awareness create empathy
in the world so people can be feel more
connected reallocated assets
otherwise be wasted here but be the
bridge then put assets here recognize
other people's value and tell him hey
you're great I think
and just reminds me of my experience of
looking in your space I'm not seeing
that and I like I'm walking like
advocating for you I'm like yeah girl go
with your values look for somebody who
matches your values so I thank you yeah
for the longest time I feel I'm really
selfish I goes through partners -
partners business partners - another one
job to another job
Boston other-- boss company finding
mentors I feel well I'm a sponge I I
suck up other people's energy and then I
felt people loved me but I couldn't
provide same amount of love back I feel
really really selfish I don't yes
I'm hearing that you're providing a lot
of love to me like a mission is just a
different way of inviting love doing it
I'm getting warmer than the personal way
of spreading love which is just yeah
yeah and you just really need to see how
you're so available to get this love and
just like this is so easy to do with you
yeah yet you're so much there yeah so I
think it now and that way I experience
you is very complex
yeah it's a lot to hold a lot of
assertiveness to hold and I know what
I'm hearing in video you're looking for
somebody who's able to comprehend all of
you and why not thank you Wow I think he
described me from a Burton looking view
that is of an higher view that I cooked
otherwise see myself I thank you so much
Wow I've just been taking you in and
just feel both honored for you revealing
yourself and I just see this diamond you
know that has some weaker facets that
are just glowing from the curiosity to
travel and see the world
to this this glow the universal love
that a vision for the world of what's
possible and it's empathy that you have
for individuals and the loss of your
father or that has tempered and cut some
of these facets in certain ways that at
times feels like a burden and a struggle
even as this this glowing pouring forth
just continues and as I see it
it just
as TPP is the perception
thank you
okay speak a lie reflect on this selfish
part because I'm learning the importance
of taking care or so bad
we go to something relationship when you
go to something like love if that's gone
then who's going to be there to take
care of you and that's something that I
wish to practice more because I was more
tending to depend on others
what am I gonna do so it's not it's not
selfish to like to want that Valley
mashed if you're not getting it you're
not satisfied
I don't feel like
you
thank you
and that's feel warm here and you say
that I don't see you as a selfish person
actually see you someone who selfless
who would come to relationship like this
is me and this is what I've got figured
out thank you
it's been like for you
I feel the world so deeply and it's very
Oh
so much energy it's like a joy to do it
we can get up we were creative yeah me
but at the same time either
I sense like it does
you
but I also share that fear who doesn't
exist I don't even know if it exists
right yeah
that compassion for you and also
I've got alone in that
anyone would be really lucky
you really yeah I just really deserved
there there are people out there
and feel as deeply as you do and like
it's like a reason they're harder to
[ __ ] it's not so there's not as many
that are like a wise boy you really
deserve to be as deeply loved
like myself
desire for you
I just feel like that exhaustion like
putting forth so much energy and like
the exhaust it's exhausting when
someone's not like you love them but
like they're not meeting you halfway but
they you rationalize it because you're
like well they just don't know yeah it's
not that fault
like you can justify anything yeah yeah
exactly such a strong
in that partnership
I once cried in the back of a lift lift
seat because the guy was cursing to the
driver for him to arrive two minutes
later than it showed on the map I was
like wow so many levels of wrongdoings
in this behavior I don't even know how
to start hmm
how hard it is for us to have more
empathy towards people around us maybe
he canceled on you because he's stuck in
a traffic because he's family meets him
now more than you need him now because
you have a lot of options having
different driver him just him by himself
there's so many possibilities you could
give other people a pass but you choose
not to and you choose curse him in front
of his face
is that the person I want to be with is
that the person I want to my children to
grow up with as a father figure
absolutely not and that those are the
moments that I had constantly Cisco Oh
unfortunately where the world supposed
to be changed by technology create by
people on the ground coding constantly
which has us most of the world spotlight
anyways yeah I just really enjoyed this
time just getting to know you I'm
hearing such a wide range of
consciousness like what I would I
interpret is consciousness so coming out
of you it's like your attention like
you're you're attentive to so many
different level of nuance and reality
and I think what I'm hearing everybody's
sort of feedback to you
it's like appreciation for the love that
that maybe maybe they're sensing a part
of you that doesn't fully let in or
doesn't appreciate in yourself perhaps
like I'm hearing like even the way you
described your name was so impactful for
me it was it was I felt both honor
respect and a yearning it's like like it
just struck me as a really high standard
like that you said and a willing and a
willing to attempt to attain right and
in the attempt to attain that there's
also a constant looking like noticing
where you're not right so like am I like
giving to the world my empathic to the
whole world am i loving the whole world
am I making it easier for people to love
because like they're loving me so it's
like easier for them to feel love right
or am i somehow being selfish right
because I'm not I'm not giving back what
they're hoping they specifically get
like rather than just awakening their
love like am I being selfish because I'm
not giving it to them in the exact way
they're wanting to experience that love
yeah even though maybe you're leaving
them better off than you found them well
yet but yet I think you're leaving them
and you know what that's like right from
the core of your childhood you know what
it's like to be left so unlike their
left you you're left with like another
level of
of empathic feeling of like their pain
of of like not being able to be fully
loved by you in the way they wanted to
right so there's so many levels of like
this empathy in this awareness right and
yet I think what I'm here for anybody
else is like but you're like you'd like
you're putting out so much love and so
much care for the world like
I think I think I already said it it's
like seems like like I'm imagining that
people come in contact with you even if
even if they end up somehow going
through some suffering because they
didn't like you're easy to love and if
they fall in love with you and then they
don't get to quote like keep you somehow
I imagine they're better off for having
known you right and having and having
that quality of love having touched them
you know and I imagine you're better off
for being able to give your love and I
think what I'm hearing from everyone is
like a desire to hold like to hold a
belief or something that that that that
person who's whose whole and complete
and has similar values and can return
that love in the same way yeah yeah yeah
kindergarten teacher yeah best
occupation for me once I passed 50 more
patient yeah less energy to jump around
yeah so we kind of went on a journey a
little bit of your life here in
exploration but I'm wondering like yeah
we're not we're not closing but we're
getting close yeah but I'm wondering
what like what's it been like for you
and and what what's different than when
we started
I feel less pity about myself whatever
less pity looks pity to myself yeah you
know sometimes you all have the moments
like this we go home we cry why this
happen to me why not other person
why didn't I was born with a silver
spoon why should I try so hard just so I
can go to the same Starbucks where you
were born a corner away immigrations
right I fell all those bitterness that's
gone at least East that yeah yeah just
connected yeah yeah less PD on yourself
be more positive keeping you I don't
know yeah I tell me David I gave out all
my vulnerability my self-doubt and my
selfishness ty felt I have and yet I
received positive response and
everybody seems kind of related to at
least part of what about what I share so
less lonely less pee do myself in more
encouragement yeah I think that thoughts
everybody can carry it's not just me if
you were here I guarantee we'll be the
same yeah yeah so you're not feeling
sorry for yourself so much and you're
getting met I walk in I cry constantly
there's no like for a lot of reasons now
I walk out I feel more confident yeah
as you can tell from my facial
expression I can't hide anything yeah oh
yeah
now you're smiling
that's very sensing answer me
agency
we're agents
more clear that I
we're just
and that is so bright and shine so you
and that is that is it's
the child has a goal that is the goal
you just translated Chinese name my
parents gave to me and to this day I try
to leave up to the mainland
let's
let's let you finish a what you're gonna
say and then let's just go around and
just say like one or two words of
something you're getting about Sophie
I feel inspired
like I know I need to go do after
hearing you talk to myself to feel like
I'm the biggest thing for me it's been
the traction I got my capital
I think those me and her agree who are a
very attractive so one one or two works
I'm inspired by
and my senses just being in that
vibrational presence of glowing like the
dawn rising and the Sun
maybe that's all that's necessary for
the life purpose it's just a vibrate at
that level and have people connect with
you on that level so that they are that
as well
being less about we need to do it in a
certain way
the biggest thing that I took from you
love needs submission and infrastructure
to actually kind of love
existing abstraction has to be part of a
mission
actually
also
it's very random but I feel the Sun is
my
I mean I love my own mother but I had a
vision few weeks ago that the
so just hear you talk about how he where
the sun is shining and everything is
just been filled you say
I really like the work she said that
infrastructure for life for love to
become a life and effect
I get
divine lover
learning how to risk receiving seven
experience not being
beautiful
here there
it's so cute like and going after it
which most people would just completely
shut down
actually
right towards our conscious relationship
conscious relationship
your vision is just such a clear and
what I associate with conscious
relationship
we're talking about crystal clear it
isn't just it encompass image you know
exactly
it may be paid
and with every relationship I'm seeing
how you become more and not less it's
added to what Abraham Hicks would say
you're read like you're filling in the
aggress and it's like every time we're
more clear about what you want and it's
become so bright and so clear that I
don't I can't say that there's somebody
out there with a hundred percent
certainty for you although I do believe
in magic and that things are coming the
minute that you wish done but all I can
reflect back is that I have seen the
fullness and the clarity what you have
and it only makes sense that that's I'm
just eating that's a very big point of
Attraction beautiful
this one aspect
what
came out of you that I thought was
relatable for so many people was shiny
from that child that that's shiny and
then how much of that shiny comes from
completing your own shiny verses finding
somebody else to complete some of the
shining and how do those two shiners
play with each other do they help
absolutely Apple buy do they actually
not that times and I found that
interplay that you made us all immersed
in to be something that so many people
as they're trying to shine go through
and have to figure out
either way
you shine yeah different levels so that
it's fine yeah
after hearing I feel inspired
how about a few last words to yourself
Wow
what are you getting your child
I thought is sharing later I felt is
connecting of being here and then later
I feel it's empowering and now I feel
relieved yeah
relief means I am still Who I am the
things I worry about as I walk in the
still in my head it's just the way I
look at it
the way I share it with people who
actually listened
reflected what the words I shared mean
to you
it's comforting encouraging
connecting less lonely
I I assign up for tonight didn't know
it's supposed it can heal me so weird
cuz I walk in I feel like I does nothing
- I wasn't coming into my old profession
cuz I should and no idea what's going on
yeah it's it's you and it's me open and
you were open to me too
why couldn't I have that before
so thank you thank you thank you all
really thank you thank you yeah
I can be your formal New York friends
thank you thank you Ron
Wow so we got to go longer Wow
there was so much more to talk about I
know yeah honestly like I didn't even
know I make sense I was basically we
didn't even touch on like what you do
for a living instantly
well I think people have to leave we can
if you want